Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day.
Let's go to the uh,
Amanda Nunez.
Ronda Rousey fight.
If you got to put some money down,
what do you,
what do you think man?
Who the fuck knows?
I love saying who the
fuck knows because you,
we haven't seen Ronda
fight in over a year.
We don't own the heads
are looking at her body.
She's in insane shape.
This a pictures of her online throwing
punches and you look at her back,
you're like,
oh leash and seeing them,
she's down.
She's down to fight.
Wake.
Wait already apparently you know,
I think losing to someone like Holly
Holm the way she did and to be tired and
get beat up and the whole deal
like look at her back there,
which is punching the speed bag.
Jesus.
That's where a donkey.
God Damn.
So if you think about the way she lost
that fight and how she looked physically,
she didn't look nothing like this.
Like not even close.
Like she's got all these videos of her
running up hills and all this different
stuff.
She looks like way more fit because she
got tired in the fight with Holly and
that was a big factor.
It's also getting hit was a big factor.
Getting stunned right away and,
but really solid conditioning will allow
you to recover better than not being in
such good shape.
Especially when you get hit in the Ed.
That's a a big factor with
the guys that are super,
super fit is how they bounce back.
You know,
like um,
Neil,
Maggie's a good example.
You can stun that guy in the first round,
but he's so fit.
He bounces back for her to that,
that Holly fight.
You should,
the one thing that Ron,
she always comes to fight,
she's always in shape.
She takes that,
you know,
personal,
it takes it upon herself to Sean have
the same sort of dedication towards that
fight with Holly that she's
got towards this fight.
Physically it doesn't let us think.
We know physically you can say that,
but we don't know cause
she'd been shooting movies.
She won't do press count.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
So we don't know.
She could take her down her
judo and not try to strike with,
they're just clinch up.
Do that judo trip.
Take her down.
Anybody's in danger of that arm bar.
That's what she's got.
That's where she's going to Mandan and
this could easily get caught in that arm
bar.
Wouldn't shock.
Here's a question for age.
Just got to drag her.
Here's a question.
Where did you guys,
do you think she has the coaching to
make changes where she just doesn't pull
forward on Amanda Nunez and
get punched in the face?
She's going to become,
of course she's going to take her time.
Of course she's not going
to go out there reckless.
She's gonna take her time.
That's how she came round
around Shit anyways,
and it seems like common sense.
Don't fucking get crazy.
Get in there and just
fucking get the blood going.
That's not her.
That's not her head.
She didn't get to man Mike Tyson,
gay sound outside and Jab and do.
She might try to overwhelm arm,
but she's not stupid.
She's going to learn from mistakes.
They just fight a cleaner fight,
more movement,
more head movement.
The surgery.
She's had knee surgery since then.
She could take Amanda down.
I think she can take cat cat,
cat,
cat Zingano had a real hard first round
and the first round in man and Nunez is
beating the shit out of her cat Nunez.
Art Cat Nunez.
Cat Cat came back and stopped new
needs that's got her on the back.
Let her down for a cardio.
If Rhonda,
again,
it's tough because what makes
Rhonda great is there's this flurry,
there's exchange.
Next thing you know you're f she
fucking hip toss you in your non bar.
Right.
And that's the thing.
She's not really gonna sit on outside.
Be patient.
That's not her.
But if she can like Vitsa a dog fight.
I think Rhonda,
I ended up catching a fourth
or fifth round cause Amanda,
she starts off like a tidal wave and
we've seen in her losses she kind of slows
down.
She just does.
Yeah.
Well it's going to be interesting to see
if American top team has been able to
do something to mitigate that.
If they've,
who knows what kind of strength
conditioning program she's under now.
The only problem I take class quick.
If Rhonda takes her
down and ends up on top,
she might have a hard time passing
Amanda Nunez Guard and we'll see like Ron
does not.
She's not known for guard passing,
so that could be a problem.
Maybe she,
she creates scrambles.
Eddie.
That's her thing,
but it's a letter to him to get up.
If she can get her on her back,
how will she,
she deal with passing the guard.
She really doesn't.
She goes to it and then she's
going to transition from there.
You got to deal with it.
With a black belt in Jujitsu,
you're going to have to
deal with the guard pass.
It's nine to really submit anybody.
It's not a right.
Rhonda can get on top of her that well.
She's a black mesh chain.
She submitted me should Tate.
She's a black belt in Jujitsu.
Sure.
After Mcmahon too.
She battered both of them
and submitted bullshit.
She what?
Both their ass is different submission
that she submits air McMahon.
She submitted a cat deaf crap.
The submitted Meesha that beat her up.
No,
not cat.
I'm sorry.
She submitted me Hsa.
She submitted nature,
that whole thing.
She did the same thing to Sarah McMahon.
I think she cracked her and then
and then put her away with a choke.
The one pretty sure the one thing she
has over Rhonda in this fight is power.
She has vicious power.
Striking.
Yeah,
and I say that's it.
I'd say that if Rhonda does
come at her full clip like that,
it's a very risky proposition.
She can crack so fucking hard,
but if Rhonda feels like
she can get closer to that.
Here we go.
She's not,
she's not dropping punch.
Right?
She's not scary.
Oh yeah.
No,
she's,
no,
I'm talking about Amanda.
Amanda Nunez.
She's working girls.
Only one shot.
She's dropping them.
And Shane a blazer.
No,
she's marking girls.
Yeah.
She needed a just clinch a punch.
As hard as you only fucking
woman in that division.
She might be the hardest women puncher
in the 135 she's the hardest one.
And Punch her outside of Cyborg.
We'll sidewalks,
not one 35 I'm just
saying females in general,
she's the hardest puncher.
Sideboards of different shit.
You want to see her fight?
Watch this.
Mine stays the same.
Do you see the fight with Nisha?
I agree.
Did you see her fight with Mischa?
Amanda Nunez.
Nisha?
I,
yes,
but I forgot all about
Amanda Nunez Stopping Misha.
She beat her up.
She wanted the belt.
Okay.
What about the Sarah McMahon fight night
go before that because before that is
when she was beating her up on the feet.
Yeah,
I was there.
She's got a nasty jab to match.
She steps in.
I'm going to distance to boom,
boom.
Good scramble.
The question is like,
is she gonna?
There's a big difference between dealing
with Rhonda and dealing with Meesha.
Look,
this is a mauling man.
She'd beat the brakes off of her.
Amanda is just putting it to me.
Should tape and you just,
she just has long ass punches
too and then she gets her back.
This size sounds are out.
If Ron is in the right frame of mind,
I think she does rush in
like she usually does.
Probably eats a shot,
but then she gets inside,
gets around to hook,
takes her for a ride and
submits in the first round.
God,
I hope nobody tests positive for anything
to so many people again.
Pop.
How about sideboard?
Yeah,
yeah.
Game over.
No matter what.
It's for game fucking over men.
Now ruins goes told Ya
fucking told ya my face.
When I watch a UFC promo these days,
I see you're skeptical,
liberal and raise you a
super skeptical snake.
That's exact.
Where for about Bro.
That's because they're
not showing Amanda Nunes.
It is kind of fucked up,
but it's also,
you know,
like someone pointed out like
when you're watching these promos,
their movies now it's
like this little film.
It's not like training footage.
People talking about it like this really
swear slickly produced movie thing.
The story is fucking great.
Oh,
Amanda Nunez.
A story's great.
Yeah.
First openly gay world champion.
Fricking Brazilian.
I mean,
knock out a highlight reel.
Highlight reels.
Yeah.
Smash her fucking work.
Like she's the devil and then,
and then we,
they don't show any Ronit chaos.
It's like that just,
it's like men in black where they just
want you to erase that from your memory.
Any of that,
plenty of that video
going around on its own.
Everybody knows what happened.
It's not something you need to discuss.
I think they could have done it in that
video and then showing the workout to
the return and it might be even
more dramatic showing her crying,
showing her building back up,
picking up the pieces again.
I mean that,
that,
I mean if you wanted to go deep,
you could.
That's going to be in the movie,
right?
If you have a Rhonda Rousey life story
movie that's gotta be in the movie course
a hundred percent if
she comes back and wins,
I mean that's exactly
what you're going to see.
You're going to see all the pain
Ronda Rousey today right now.
I mean she is who she is right now.
What's going on right now is because
what happened with Holly Holm,
you know this is her comeback does,
is it can't you pull off the comeback?
I mean,
the only reason you can
come back against who,
like I said,
the average fan is going come
back against who she's been,
the favorite and every
fight she's ever been,
had a complete blackout of Amanda Nunez.
Like they haven't showed shit at all.
It does very little footage that
they're showing in these problems.
They're showing Nunez.
Stop watching boxing as
to put it back on fucking,
yeah,
cause I don't see an fs one.
No,
they're on boxing.
That work.
I'll that Joe tweeted
them know I tweeted a big,
like while I was watching it at home,
I was watching,
I was actually in a hotel room.
I was watching that UFC on Fox where
Michelle Waterson beat Paige vanzant and I
was watching.
I'm like,
this is so bizarre.
They're not showing the champion to
show in this giant Promo and it's all
Rhonda,
which makes some sense because
Rhonda is huge and she,
you want to let everybody
know that she's coming back.
But don't you want to let everybody know
that she's coming back against a killer
against you?
Want everybody know that she's coming
back to fight the champion Joe?
Just just from a business aspect.
What in some weird world in MMA,
what if Amanda Nunez Mercer in
the first year she has look,
no one knows it.
Yes.
Is one of them.
One of them.
You seen her face to see her face,
but like most of the pieces about Rhonda,
but there's a few of these,
right?
It was a few different ones.
Do you know?
Do you know what I'm saying?
Joe?
What happened that she melts Ron here,
they're showing,
they showed her head kick and you look
at the Saudis to somebody else's trailer,
Bro.
This isn't created shit.
Trying to find the real one.
That's okay.
You don't have to.
It's a lot longer than
an actual promo too.
Like how long has that video right there?
Those two minutes?
Yeah.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Jail.
What happens if some weird,
some weird MMA world.
A man,
his word is weird at
all and then we're gone.
Do you think that's weird?
Not at all.
No.
It's real dangerous.
Marcy is acting like it.
They're putting all their chips in this
basket where if Amanda Nunez does her
thing and it happens,
people go,
that was one,
but Rhonda is a thousand
times more popular.
They're not popular then Amanda Nunez.
Hundred percent a hundred percent
where the money's coming from money.
But every,
okay.
You've already established she,
Rhonda is it,
but hold on.
You're already establishing
the Ron is fighting.
What do you want everybody to know?
She's fighting a killer.
Who she fighting?
That's what we're tuning him for.
You.
You'll see the matchup.
Alright.
Just selling it as if the whole thing
that you're seeing is her coming back.
Yeah,
but I'm saying in some,
in business one on one,
what happened if that other person wins
and we don't know shit about her UFC
channel,
this is it.
Yeah.
There's just not much of it.
I just don't see a bunch of different,
if she wins then they'll blow her up.
There's still timing.
We have a deadline.
If she willing can
fight Ronda Rousey once,
get this one we manage.
Maybe or twice.
There's no room or no it was,
but at least you know that's
the girl that beat my met.
She'll be just like Holly Holm,
instantly huge.
And I'm on fucking
Ellen and all that shit.
Holly's in an interesting place to
write cause she was instantly huge.
And then she loses two in a row.
Two straight.
Yeah.
And she loses to,
to like two completely different styles.
She gets choked out by Meesha
against a better grappler.
And then she gets a check the lot by
volunteership Chenko and Mount Tina.
Just,
I would like to see that
promo if it's possible.
Jamie at the UFC,
one of the on the UFC.
Youtube.
I know it's youtube,
but there's no real bro.
It's not real.
It's you lie on Youtube.
So here's her like in the top of her
feet and promos from iron bar and people,
you get them from CNN.
We all know that.
Smashing people.
So this is uh,
is this the same one as the card?
She uses a different one.
This is the Holly Holly.
So this is going to show
it at the end of November.
What happened there?
They don't show show it.
They cut.
Oh they go black.
And then you see Holly winning.
Wow.
See what she,
what she likes skeptical.
Snake.
Well you got to go down more than
it has to be done more actually.
Like you see he's up.
Cause he's progression of his mouth
and the progression of the belt.
You see the progression of the belt,
but you don't see her getting head kicked.
That's crazy.
Why would you not show the highlight?
Wow.
What will you doing is you're showing
preferential treatment for one athlete
without a doubt.
And the idea is that the ability
and the fame that she's reached you,
you show preferential treatment
because she's different.
She's special.
She's different.
She's doing massive star.
She is a massive star.
That's the,
that's the girl that's going to put
this the asses in the seats right there.
Man.
She's got bigger than Conor though.
I think you're right.
But as far as women go,
she is the,
the corner of the timeout.
I'm done about fighters.
Oh yeah.
I'm,
his division is not even close.
No,
not even close.
There's no one like there's no one like,
but just cause Connors sells more
tickets doesn't mean she's an,
they have multiple stores,
multiple elite stars and she,
and here you see Amanda
doing some workouts,
you know,
just lifting some words.
Girlfriend's a strawweight
in the EOC is she?
Yeah.
World Bantamweight champion.
Amanda Nunez.
And you see some highlights.
So this one is showing more.
So this is a different one than the one
where they roll up the one that they see
on TV where they roll up the garage
door and he's here hitting the pads.
Pop up and that's it.
Yeah,
please.
Good though.
It looks good doing that.
Very interesting man.
Flash thing.
Who the fuck knows who the fuck knows?
I'm just know you're going to be watching.
Everyone's going be watching.
Yeah.
It's going to be crazy,
man.
Crazy nuts going to be crazy.
I don't think would be
surprised by the ratings.
You don't think anybody was watching?
No,
I'm not saying that somebody to hate her.
no,
no.
I'm not a hater.
I'm hating on the promotional gay.
I understand.
I understand what you're saying.